So,
uh,
we're discussing,
in this MDL was every,
sorry,
we're discussing the fertility transition and we've talked that prior to the
fertility transition,
there was a control on fertility,
but it was at a very high level and
you add in different parts of the world.
We talked in very general terms about it.
I want to just describe a little bit about what the story was in Europe,
exactly how,
uh,
fertility was controlled.
And one of the main reasons that I've mentioned this before but not really
described it,
is control of marriage.
That the number of people that were allowed to in some sense get married,
changed with economic conditions and agricultural conditions.
And you can see that very clearly where we get statistics from the period.
So as you know,
uh,
the first year of the black death was this 13,
47,
1348 and huge numbers of people died and good.
Their land was immediately taken over by someone else.
Immediately these new landowners got married,
got married.
There was an enormous burst of marriage.
So like in one small French village,
there had been 10 to 12 marriages a year in the preceding decade.
In 1349,
the first year after that phase of the plague past,
he'd win,
uh,
from 10 to 12 to 86 marriages and an enormous thing.
And so what was going on is there was a,
before the black death when Europe was crowded for,
for its system,
uh,
there was a huge pool of unmarried,
individuals who really wanted to get married but did not have any land on which
to support themselves or a family.
And the opening of the land allows marriage to take place.
And then not only did they get married right away,
but the women got pregnant immediately.
And one contemporary observer wrote,
there are pregnant women wherever you look,
and this is 1349.
So up and this fertility rate,
it was a flexible system that moved up and down according to Emma economic and
demographic conditions in England,
there's data from the 1550s,
and,
and later the grocery production rate.
That's the number of women from w are certain number of women in one generation.
How many female children do they produce in the 1550s,
it was 2.8.
So one will reproduce a woman.
The grocery we've got for it should be one,
but they were producing 2.8.
A century later it drops down to 1.8,
and by that 1650s and by eighties,
it rises again to over three.
So there's enormous range between,
uh,
one,
close to one less than two,
just reproducing themselves,
getting into this dangerous thing where very high death rates,
where the whole society at that rate won't continue.
And a factor of three women,
which will do just fine.
So you can see the same thing at the age of marriage.
Uh,
know the numbers of marriage of course,
but the age of marriage,
uh,
during the early 18 hundreds,
remember that was a time when the,
you're the,
you're American foods.
They're European population was rising strong as a high birth rate.
So land hunger became the land.
There was no extra land available.
So marriage became later and later and eventually reached 23 to 28,
uh,
for females and even older than that,
for males.
So by that time,
probably the average lifespan with like 35 that had improved some.
But if,
if you're fertile at say 15 and you don't marry till 28,
that's a huge chunk of your reproductive life where you're not reproducing.
That reduces the birth rate and keeps the population in check
whoever.
Once in marriage,
the children just just flowed that there was no apparently no control or within
marriage whatsoever.
So in 300 year,
all the data that we have says that in 300 years in Europe,
there was no control of fertility within marriage.
All the control,
all the social control of population was in how many people got married,
what they called the nuptial reality,
that the fraction of people that got night was the total mechanism of social
control.
There's of course a external control by,
by disease,
by famines because some plague of the plants.
And then there were individual controls,
which we've talked about infanticide and and so forth.
But in terms of social controls,
the north through Northwestern,
the northern Europeans,
especially in Northwestern European model was control marriage and it was quite
effective.
But these,
uh,
these marriage controls didn't just happen automatically.
People just didn't sort of have a rational sense of this at all.
I can't get married there.
There was really the,
the controls were forced upon them.
So,
uh,
most land was owned by some land owner and the man was given a plot of land,
which he could work.
It was a size,
so that one individual could work this plot of land.
He starts having children.
Well,
Lou,
the landlord knows that only one,
one son is needed to farm that land.
So,
uh,
and the father knows he can only give that land to one son.
So there's tremendous pressure.
If you have extra children,
they can't stay at home.
You'll see when we talked about China,
very different model.
If he can't stay home,
those people are forced off to the cities and in the cities,
the cities are very dangerous and disease ridden places.
So they just die in the cities and the cities are growing.
During this time,
but very high death rates still on the cities,
about one third.
Each generation has to be replenished as I've mentioned to by about one third in
the cities.
Um,
so in the landlord of course didn't want these extra children around cause he
would have more and more people to feed with the same amount of land,
therefore the same amount of product production.
So you had to get the landlord's permission in order to get married.
And if you didn't,
if he didn't have extra land for you,
you couldn't get married.
And of course,
officially it wasn't the landlord,
but it was the local parish church that you had to get married in.
But guess who hired the parish?
A minister or a priest,
the local landlord.
And the whole structure of churches almost everywhere is that they are very much
either controlled by or mutual support of the,
the Gentry,
the rich people and the religious authorities intermix.
So,
uh,
they weren't allowed to get married either by the landlord or by,
by the church.
And it was very,
you had to post what they called bands.
So everybody knew there was a marriage and of course the landlord would notice.
And so it was,
it was impossible to do anything about that.
Another mechanism was going off becoming a servant.
That was one of the very standard kinds of things.
Um,
they would,
uh,
leave home,
very young,
become servant and serve males and females,
both servants in the houses.
You've all seen all these Victorian movies and earlier movies.
You know how many servants they have.
Of course,
they were never allowed to get married.
Uh,
no allowed to have sex.
No,
no boyfriend,
no girlfriend,
none of that was a lot.
Very,
very strict rules on how servants and how students were very large fraction
of the young people of,
of everybody in say England.
Um,
then those that didn't become servants would go off somewhere to become an
apprentice.
You know,
one son stays at home.
It does go off and become apprentices.
And apprenticeship was a very long period of time in which they had to learn the
skills and get,
um,
get some sort of resources so that they could buy the equipment and rent a shop
and set up eventually on their own or wait until the master died and then
inherit the masters,
uh,
place.
So the,
the end result of all this is that it took many,
many years to establish a sufficient economic base so that the society would
allow you to get married and many people never gotten out of it.
I'll show you a little bit later what the marriage rates,
actually we're in Europe or during this period and it's surprisingly low in the
culture adapts to this.
What do all these unmarried men and women do?
But you have the spinster,
the spinster a woman,
you have the confirmed bachelor.
Again,
using men in much British comedy in British movies is about,
always has characters in it where,
you know,
some confirmed bachelor,
he's just not getting married.
Uh,
presumably a fair amount of the homosexuality that was president,
especially in the British upper classes,
is due to this whole tradition that a lot of nails are not going to get married.
And then they do something else with their sexual impulse.
Of course,
that's not proven.
We don't really understand the basis of homosexuality.
Uh,
females.
we're also do like the males a forced off the land because they were not the
wife of the,
the one son that inherited the land.
They had to go somewhere else.
So they went to the cities where there were not jobs,
especially not jobs for women.
Um,
so,
uh,
they become,
sort of a floating population,
a very largely prostitutes,
huge explosion of prostitution at this time,
both because of the excess women that are trying to,
to stay alive,
that have migrated into the cities and there's all these bachelors,
they're having some sort of job that could pay for their services.
So,
and of course,
you know,
that babies that resulted from any of these situations were very often just
abandoned and left to die.
So this control of marriage,
that that marriage was the control on pop,
the social control on population lasted well into the 18 hundreds well into and
possibly even through the Victorian era and these mechanisms together reduced,
uh,
the north European birth rate and especially in England to about 50% of what
otherwise could have been that remember we did calculations of someone goes out,
how many children one can have and then there's always examples much to the high
end of that.
But in England,
taking a reasonable number,
these controls of marriage cut the birth rate in half.
Okay.
So what did it feel like to the people involved in this?
And I suspect a fair number of you have,
uh,
heard this quote,
it's a letter from a woman to her uncle.
Don't,
don't shout out the,
raise your hand if you know,
I think dearest uncle that you cannot really wish me to be the mother of a
numerous family for,
I think you will see the great inconvenience in a large family would be the
hardship to myself.
Men never think what a hard task it is for us women to go through this pregnancy
very often.
Have you heard this?
No.
No one's heard this letter.
It's very famous.
So this is a woman in this system,
the way she,
and she's married and therefore she's having cha children one after the other
with no kind of control.
And she's coming.
This is hard on me,
you know?
And why don't you man ever think how hard this is on me.
You know?
So,
uh,
what social class,
this poor woman,
middle class and upper class woman having all this way,
no ideas.
It's Queen Victoria.
So here's by far the richest woman in the world has all the help,
all the money,
all the food.
And even for her it's a burden.
And she probably doesn't have to do much of the burden except just straight up
of the pregnancy and childbearing.
And if she perceives it as a burden,
then can you imagine what the common woman thinks of it?
Oh,
and by the way,
so it's,
it's Queen Victoria to her uncle who is king Leopold of Belgium.
You've heard this before.
And so
when,
well,
let's see,
this is one of the things that,
ah,
so sexuality itself,
uh,
since I made it a lot of problems with sexuality at that time,
you'd reading some stuff about it.
And one of the things is that men inside from the childbirth aspect of it,
that women were of course always worried that if they had sex,
they would get pregnant.
And often they did usually even they probably did not want to get pregnant,
but also the men were not,
uh,
very skilled.
They either did not know how to pleasure a woman,
uh,
they didn't want to or they thought it was very improper to,
even tried us to pleasure a woman.
So here's another quote,
uh,
from Lady Alice Huntington.
Hilling,
sorry.
Hillingdon 1857,
uh,
and she died only in 1940.
So we're really coming up to a fairly recent kinds of times.
And presumably this was written in your journal in 1912.
No one can find that journal.
So they don't know the state of pro how apocryphal this is.
But this is a quote that again,
you've probably heard at least part of it.
I'm happy now.
The George,
her husband calls in my bed chamber less frequently than then of old as it is I
now endure,
but two calls a week.
And when I hear his steps outside my door,
I lied down upon my bed,
close my eyes,
open my legs.
And think of England.
Sometimes the code is,
think of Victoria and budget apparently think of England is the proper.
And again,
we're not talking about some poor woman with a brutal husband is in some Oliver
twist or one of these movies.
This is a,
a very high uh,
stage lady.
Um,
so how did this change and who,
who was arrayed against this?
So,
uh,
people,
women especially,
we're not happy with the situation.
A young man of course wanted to get married,
couldn't chill.
They were old.
We've talked about that situation in Africa where the bride price is very high.
The old men control the bride price.
They don't allow the young men to get married until it was almost a revolution.
And this is an aside,
but with respect to the bride price,
you know,
we hear a lot about older men,
uh,
marrying or having sex with younger women in the West.
It's one of the things we sort of complain about,
about other,
other cultures at this great disparity in age and older man with a younger
woman.
And we tend to blame the man who's getting married.
But if you think of it from the point of view,
their society,
that man has been under the control of even older guys,
the really powerful guys.
And so he's been abused and not allowed to get married til he sold the women of
his age already married to the much older guys.
So this is his only option.
So again,
within a society,
uh,
these things all intermingle and,
and,
and form a pattern,
not necessarily a good pattern,
not necessarily a pattern that the people,
uh,
like.
Uh,
but it is a,
it is a tight web.
Uh,
coming back to Europe,
this was this unfortunate situation where young men weren't allowed to get
married.
Young women weren't allowed to get married.
Once you're in marriage,
the sexual mores were so straight jacketed that it was not certainly not
pleasurable for most of the women apparently.
And who knows what the men were using it.
But the Victorian pornography during this period is lots of Mres,
lots of prostitution and lots of of being whipped.
They,
they love to get punished,
uh,
themselves.
A surprising perponderance of a masochistic sexuality in the Victorian
literature of that time.
So at least from our point of view,
uh,
sexuality was a mess.
Okay.
So some people tried to change this.
Of course there's always pioneers.
And in England,
uh,
one of the pioneers was a,
a man and a woman.
Uh,
Charles,
Brad Law and Annie an 1877,
uh,
family planning was,
contraception was coming into a possibility in England.
And so they distributed,
printed and distributed what we would now consider a very mild,
a pamphlet about birth control called the fruits of philosophy because very
abstract falls,
you know,
philosophical.
So,
of course what happened to them,
arrested and died and the official an indictment accused them of inciting and
encouraging the subjects of the queen to indecent,
obscene,
unnatural and immoral practices.
And to bring them,
the citizens,
the citizens of the Queen,
the subjects of the queen to a state of wickedness.
Lewdness and a Boucherie.
This is because they were saying that,
well,
there's these things called condoms around and you know,
why don't you use them?
MMM.
And this trial was very interesting that in a culture you,
there are certain things you can't talk about.
If something is culturally forbidden,
like almost anything to do with sex in marriage,
you're just couldn't talk about it.
Now here's this big trial in London,
very famous.
All the newspapers are carrying it.
And guess what?
Everybody learns about birth control and a very big thing.
And some scholar,
some historians attribute,
uh,
that there's just the period when,
when the use of birth control is increasing tremendously in England.
And that this trial popularized it.
What do we have something similar a few years ago in America
with our president,
Bill Clinton and oral sex?
Or you all too young to remember that was a taboo,
taboo topic.
You could not discuss it.
And then the right,
the right wing,
the conservatives who are opposed to this kind of free sexual activity
publicized it and publicize and publicize until every teenager in America knew
about oral sex.
And now the data is that oral sex is just gone exponentially down into the high
schools and even junior high schools.
And I can tell you stories about that,
but I won't.
Um,
so with all this,
uh,
moralizing about it,
that,
uh,
the religious leaders,
the political leaders,
uh,
the medical doctors said it was,
it was bad for you.
You've read some of that in your reading.
Uh,
everybody is,
uh,
they were terrorized in,
in a sense that it was an intellectual terrorism.
One of the people that they feared legal process,
prosecution and most of these things were illegal to buy things,
to use thing to write about them and publish them.
Uh,
they were told that they would get physical injury.
You may have heard that,
you know,
masturbation will make you blind.
And that,
I don't know if any of your parents said that,
but I heard it in my time.
Uh,
mental injury,
if it doesn't make you blind,
it'll make you go crazy and deep moral reservations and just straight aesthetic
d this taste,
um,
that,
you know,
when the society frowns on something,
we sort of have incorporated a kind of revulsion to anything which society
considers a disgusting.
And contraceptives themselves were considered repulsive,
unnatural only for prostitutes,
that kind of thing.
And of course at that time,
almost a lot of people were starting to do it,
but since you couldn't talk about it publicly,
no one knew what everyone else is doing.
So they make what they had to take this great leap themselves in defiance of
everything that their culture,
uh,
is,
is telling them.
So how did it,
how,
what happened in individual is starting to think about these things.
So we have,
uh,
some interesting and what a lot of,
a lot of letters,
a lot of interesting stuff and uh,
referred to in the reading.
Some of this is in your reading letters to various pioneers,
Margaret Sanger or,
um,
who has it in England,
the,
uh,
and for blocking on the name of the clinic in England,
we have letters from women sort of begging information on how to,
how to keep from getting pregnant again,
but a lot of it is,
is not with any official organizations,
women talking to women.
And some of it can be relaxed it a little bit later stage.
So there's a,
a series of Nice interviews from the 1920s and thirties,
um,
with elderly,
Italian and Jewish women in the United States.
And,
uh,
they talk to each other about technique because techniques is one of the thing.
And this interview is from an Italian American woman
born in the night,
uh,
born in the u s in 1920.
A recent immigrant parents.
And the conversation took place in the late 1930s.
She works in a hairdressing salon and shortly she gets engaged and of course,
all her coworkers know about it.
And so an interviewer,
anthropologists or sociologists goes in and starts asking her about it.
And apparently prior to this little quote they had brought up the topic of birth
control.
So the interviewer says,
how did you learn about condoms to Nina?
One of my customers said,
I really hope you don't get pregnant,
let him wear a rain coat.
So I started wondering,
I'm thinking I'm working and my mind just can't work out on a raincoat is,
and then Mary White who worked for me,
he said,
baby,
what's on your mind?
And I said,
Mrs. Jacobs said a funny thing to me.
She said,
my ring was lovely or marriage ring.
Uh,
uh,
was lovely,
but she hoped I didn't start a family and he should wear a raincoat,
but I can't ask Johnny to wear rain to bed.
And so this Mary White laughed and laughed and says she means he used to wear a
condom.
What is it Nina said?
And then she got told and got enlightened in this way.
And it's that kind of conversation where individual people have,
you know,
not very high class are learning that it's okay to buck the trend.
And,
and even the basic information they previously don't,
don't have.
It doesn't always work out that when these discussions take place,
that the,
that the participants do take on the new behavior,
sometimes they don't want to want to do that.
And gossip,
most conversation by humans is gossip.
And there's,
there's very good studies showing this.
And we know that from our chimp days were very social species.
That status is so terribly important and status translates to social
acceptability.
So the purpose of gossip is to find out what the limits of social acceptability
are.
Gossip is almost exclusively about someone who has stepped over what was
perceived to be the limit and either gotten away with it or not gotten away with
it or something that's down just inside the limit.
So large fraction of gossip is to see what is socially acceptable in my circle.
And sometimes like we've seen here,
the use of condoms become socially acceptable as a result of discussions like
this.
Sometimes it,
it,
at least this individual at this time,
uh,
it doesn't become
acceptable.
Now where's this other quote that I'm just looking for?
Ah,
so this is,
uh,
another two women,
and the interview asks,
how did your friends have abortions?
The issue of abortions came up and as you probably have read or will read
abortions at this time,
a very,
very common all illegal.
Uh,
but very common.
Peggy,
I'm trying to think what they would take because they tell me a lot of them
would have a friend who had put something up there that would bring on their
period,
the interviewer,
a knitting needle.
Peggy,
no,
not a knitting needle.
Some kind of fluid like hot boiling water or salt water.
They would ruin their insides.
They would say,
oh,
Peggy,
don't you,
don't you do that?
Oh No,
I would never do that.
That's my husband.
It's the man who takes care.
And,
uh,
and it's interesting that in this particular case,
you know,
it's usually a woman's responsibility,
most good.
But in this case,
whenever it was going on in the marriage,
she perceived it as the husband's case and in further discussion that it was his
responsibility to use a condom all the time.
So,
uh,
and the reason given by the woman is not any moral consideration,
no life.
You know,
I'm saying get away that,
that's not the consideration,
but it's straight a medical thing.
It's just at that time,
the math,
the,
since it was illegal and if you didn't,
even if you went to a practitioner was very,
very dangerous,
but the kinds of things that women actually used on themselves rather than it
was so incredibly dangerous.
So the reason she's not having an abortion is that she didn't want to ruin
herself in,
in a medical,
uh,
sort of way.
You take this same woman transposer 50 years later,
we're now abortion is safe and possibly illegal.
Uh,
she,
the same woman may have a very different attitude toward it,
but of course we don't know anything about that.
So the,
the point of this,
uh,
these series of stories is a big change in,
in,
in culture that prior the,
you know,
every society has to control population in some way.
And we've talked about,
you know,
the physical constraints,
the disease and famines.
We've talked about the social controls,
like not being able to get married,
but up until in,
in,
in Europe,
up until very recently,
there was no individual control.
Individuals themselves did not have the cultural freedom to make these kinds of
decisions.
Once married,
procreation just keep,
keeps going one after the other until either someone dies or the woman becomes
infertile.
And so now we're seeing a transition where individuals can start deciding for
themselves very big change,
uh,
in the extension of agency that what a person thinks they can control about
their lives.
So here is a,
uh,
an elderly Jewish woman,
was,
uh,
report talking about her mother and said that the,
the way the neighbors now start controlling this,
uh,
she,
the,
so the mother who did not use any kind of of fertility control,
her friends and relatives who sort of get on her case,
but mile trainers who are mildly,
when she would get pregnant,
they would say,
oh,
Esther,
not another belly.
And so at this time,
uh,
friends,
relatives,
neighbors start imposing a new culture on you that there's,
you know,
you can be,
there's some aspects of freedom that the individual now gets to choose.
But the culture comes on and now at least starts to import a new cultural norm
on you.
So,
uh,
in Sicily,
you know,
reputed to have very high ha actually having high fertility rates,
but some point they go through their transition.
And this is,
uh,
in 1980 and the 1980s,
very late and [inaudible] is a report of a woman who's one of the few remaining
peasants in this village.
You know,
Sisley like all the rest of the world is changing and growing up.
And she reported that of,
of the,
these family that's still had child after child after child,
their neighbors called them animals.
And this is,
you know,
Sicilian two,
two Sicilian,
uh,
is another example of this,
a Jewish immigrant in the u s writing to her mother back in,
in Poland.
So this is a lovely letter here in America.
It is the customer that if a woman wants to,
she has a baby and if she does not want to have any,
she doesn't.
David's wife,
I don't know that that's a brother or something.
David's wife says that she will have a baby every four years.
I think it is good to have one every three years.
And so after three years,
I shall have another,
it is terrible cut at home.
Women suffer only hardships and childbearing whom being Poland,
uh,
in,
in this case.
And it's,
it's really interesting that the technology is not of interest to her.
She doesn't,
in this case,
talking about the wonderful new contraceptives that they have in America,
which of course they would not have had,
uh,
in,
in Poland.
Uh,
nor about the availability of the knowledge about it,
the availability of the technology of it.
She doesn't talk about economics.
Uh,
she doesn't say,
Oh,
we can't afford it or we can't afford her and any of that sort of stuff.
She's talks about what to hers is startling new idea that's under her control,
that she can choose herself,
what to do and someone else can make a different,
uh,
kind of a choice.
And what she's,
what she's a exuberant about is the lack of cultural constraints.
She's now a free individual to navigate the world as she sees it in herself.
Um,
okay.
There's one that I,
And also when these,
in all these discussions,
men are rarely mentioned.
It really is sort of a women's,
a decision here and the,
and the women are working it out.
And again,
in most of these things,
well and a lot of these things,
uh,
sometimes it is the man and you know,
no matter what I say,
he won't stay away from me.
But once the contraception comes in that men want to sex and you get a lot of
conflict,
if they're not using contraception,
contraception comes in.
It seems to be much easier to manage,
uh,
the females.
And so you have
read some of this in,
in,
in your readings.
So
until the demographic.
Uh,
so now I'm going to go back to talking about marriage until the demographic
revolution.
As I said,
the marriage rates were controlled by the community,
not the individual.
And let's look at the marriage rates here.
I can find them without,
so,
uh,
whoops.
That's not what,
what I might want it.
Yeah.
So this is Belgium in various provinces in Belgium and Belgium.
As you know,
it's a totally Catholic country.
And we will talk a little bit more about Belgium in a minute.
And here the dates from,
from before the,
uh,
the transition to 1970,
very recent.
This is the end of the marital index.
What fraction got married?
And look at that 40%,
only 40% of people got married in that year,
that ever,
ever married.
So that more than half of people are not getting,
getting married.
And we think of the old days is,
as you know,
everybody had to get married.
No.
And then as time goes on,
as the fertility transition takes places,
people are interested or having fewer and fewer children within marriage,
the marriage rate goes up drastically until it's like 70,
75%,
which is kind of a modern rate.
And the same thing,
this is another set of provinces and other set of provinces.
There's an tour plays the big cities and Luxembourg,
which I'd not have provinces in Belgium.
So,
uh,
a very interesting thing is that again,
keeping in mind that societies have to control their fertility.
If you're controlling marriage,
if you don't have any mechanism contraception,
then when people get married,
they're going to have babies.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
So you have to control one Mac,
one method,
you have to control the number of marriages.
So you control it extremely 40%.
Now just in China,
we're going to talk about China later.
Do you know what the rate of,
uh,
so there,
there the American's complain and Chinese too to some degree about the one child
policy and the excess of female of males that there aren't enough girls to get
married.
And this is going to cause incredible social disruption.
You know what,
you know what the rate,
how,
what the absence of females is there at maximum like 15 or 18%.
And so nothing like,
and here 60% of people aren't getting,
getting married and the Chinese situation is still above.
They,
if,
if all the males,
if all the females get married,
something like 85% of men can get married.
So if you compare China and Europe,
you see it's,
it's again,
it's not necessarily reality based thing.
This,
this worry about,
uh,
the male female ratio come back here.
This is,
uh,
no,
I ain't gonna have to get my glasses.
This is a map of Europe and the whole of Europe,
including Russia.
And this is 1870 and 1870.
[inaudible].
This is from the Princeton project and every one of these little things as a
province of Europe and every one of these provinces,
they've collected data on everything under the sun for,
and this is the marriage rate.
So look here,
the red is less than 30% when you have an occasion place in northern Scotland.
I think this is bold.
Uh
Oh,
just this.
Let's see.
North Italy,
there's not Bulgaria Bulgaria's or more over here.
I can't tell from the map,
but it's a province in southeast,
but look at the red here.
That's under 40% of people are getting married and then some of the lighter
stuff you get into the 40 to 50% and the same truth.
We're middle of Europe,
Germany,
Austria,
Switzerland,
Scandinavia,
Finland,
all through here.
You're all in the 50 and less.
Less than 50% of people are getting married.
1870 little bit.
In Spain,
you get up into a more reasonable range and you have to go all the way out to
the Caspian Sea.
The board of the cans,
Mitzi defined people getting married,
80% of people getting married and a number that we consider something sort of
reasonable for are not,
not now because marriage was rate is falling,
but that was the general preconception of Westerners going up in our society is
that for time and memorial,
almost everybody got married,
but it's not not the case.
The Eastern Europe,
which was in a rather different mold,
had a higher marriage rate.
Now you look at this,
this is 1870.
When you come up to after the fertility of transition and look,
looks at what happened.
Everybody's going bluish,
right?
Marriage has just shot up all over Europe.
Hooding out here.
It actually went,
got less.
These,
these are sort of doing reverse,
but western Europe where we have,
you know,
lots and lots of good data and understanding,
there's almost nothing pink left.
And guests now who has the lowest,
uh,
marriage rate,
Ireland,
what's special about Ireland at this time?
Catholic and no,
no contraception.
So they're not allowed to get married there back in the 30,
40%.
And that's sort of,
uh,
you know,
very characteristic of,
of the sociology of Ireland that the men are very close to their mother and get
married at a very later,
don't get,
get married at all.
Whereas England,
they're Protestant neighbor with sharing all kinds of other cultural aspects is
up there in the 70,
75% of marriage.
So that's one of the really kinds of things that that happened that basically
the spread of marriage that in,
in Europe,
different story,
other parts of the world that Matt,
because of the need to control total population.
In the old days,
people just weren't allowed to get married because once they were in marriage,
they weren't allowed to use contraception.
Once you,
once you flip that equation and open up to individual decision,
there's no requirement in all of this.
There's no requirement that people use contraception,
but fam,
families naturally want to have fewer children than they would have naturally.
And so fertility in a family,
uh,
declines.
The social control of marriage is not needed anymore.
And marriage rate,
uh,
goes,
goes up very high.
And of course,
along with marriage,
uh,
that I call this democratizes that marriage gets democratized.
And of course,
sex gets democratized prior to this,
all these,
you know,
all these people that aren't married either have no sex and they have homosexual
sex.
They go to prostitutes.
I mean they,
they,
we don't know much about how much sex they had,
but they had one sort of sex and that was what society demanded of them.
Normal marital sex was not allowed in a very small fraction,
were able to get married in sex.
So along with the democratization of marriage,
you'll also get the democratization of sex.
So,
um,
good.
Let's,
let's look at some of the details.
All of this happening.
Oh,
well I've got these pictures.
These big maps are hard for the computer to calculate apparently.
Come on.
What is going on here?
So this is some of the,
uh,
the contraceptives that were coming in at this time.
Some of the,
there's,
there's museum does several museums in the world that get all the countries.
One is just stones putting stones in the universe.
These others sort of various forms of,
of blocking of the canal to absorb this and the semen.
And you put cotton or something in a little bag like this,
put it in the vagina and then present that,
have these all help.
This,
I don't know exactly what that is,
but again,
some blocking substance.
Then they can be made not only a vegetable matter,
but metal.
There's a whole bunch of things called pessaries where the,
uh,
cat,
which is some,
a cap made out of porcelain or something put over the cervix.
Um,
there are,
this is,
uh,
a variety of condoms,
including some fairly modern ones.
The older ones.
This is an old way.
They're made older ones look like this.
And what do you think was the,
how they originally made condoms?
What the technology was borrowed from something else?
What else comes very commonly purchased item come sausages,
exactly that.
The,
and what and what,
what was before there's plastics,
what was sausage casings made out of intestines,
animal intestines.
They can be made very thin because they're,
they're supposed to be as just a small barrier for absorption and they're very
thin.
And so they were called skins and I don't know which of these things are which,
but,
um,
uh,
that was not a very difficult technology to make them out of skins.
And here are some more modern things,
various kinds of IUD.
You know,
everything under the sun,
uh,
was tried including the more modern,
oops,
that's the wrong one.
Come back
when this is being so slow.
And this is very ancient technique.
You know,
people at different times of believe that almost anything works as it comes to
this is a bone on a string.
Again,
placed inside and heavens know what the theory was,
white and that would work in it might've just prevented the man from entering
foreign off or something.
Who Knew?
Who knows?
Uh,
but these,
the,
the string,
it likes like a modern Iud,
whereas in the string hangs out and you can go down.
And what are one of the problems with modern ids until recently?
And the same problem here,
you have a string.
What does the string do?
Route for bacteria to,
to,
to swim up.
So the strings are,
are,
are dangerous things.
Okay,
let me get back to the beginning
this a little bit and no,
this is good.
Come on.
So,
so now we've talked about individuals sort of in a variety of ways.
How,
how this happened,
individuals and cultural thing here has this,
you didn't,
this wasn't in your reading,
this particular graph.
So here is a graph of the date again,
Europe,
the different countries of Europe and when,
what they're of within marriage,
what their rate of fertility was within marriage with actually 1.0 being the
Hutter right level,
which is the maximum level people haven't achieved.
And what do you make out of that?
It's kind of a mess,
right?
You can see something,
you can see France being lower already by 1860 we know it had its transition and
you can't really see much else.
But one of the data that that you read about,
if you take those same graphs and now change their time thing and they ask,
well let's gather each graph at the point visit true traditional level of
fertility,
age or so children and in each country may be a little different,
somewhere between six and eight and then at some point it starts to drop.
And when it's dropped by 10% is a critical stage.
So the Princeton people argued,
and so they've gathered,
this is the years,
uh,
after reaching the 90% patrols.
So at this point in time,
all of these countries have dropped these,
these curves are gathered to put together the point where they reach 10% drop
from there pre transition level,
and then it makes more sense.
Look at the way that falls down like crazy until it hits some sort of roughly a
new plateau at about half or so of the earlier plateau,
a little bit less than half.
And the amount of time here,
this is zero years and it's all over maybe in 50 years.
And if you look at any one place,
it's much shorter period than that.
So within a very,
what Princeton decided a couple of things,
one that hard to figure out,
but there was,
for some reason various groups started their fertility decline and we'll talk
about various theories of that.
But once it became,
where's everyone else was horrified about whatever these,
they say it was rich people,
it was outcast people.
Uh,
how did,
how did it in a mirror?
So it was upperclass the fertility clinic happened first of all,
upper class men,
city class among Jews.
And so it's always some sort of a,
of a mark of a,
of a non majority social group that starts social change.
What made the discussion of condoms,
uh,
legitimate in America?
You know,
when I was in you could not mention condom,
no,
no television discussion of it.
News reports never mentioned it.
And what is it that allowed condoms to be discussed in America?
You know,
wow.
Alone
AIDS epidemic.
And where did the AIDS epidemic started?
Homosexuals.
So a marginalized group start something.
It spreads into the culture where to wear clothing.
Fashions often come from the poorest kids.
Often I can see,
uh,
you know,
go into the ghetto and see what the kids are wearing.
And six years later you guys are going to be wearing exactly what,
what they are wearing,
long baggy pants and so forth and showing various parts.
Okay.
So the idea is one,
that's something happens up here and there's a lot of discussion about that.
But once it becomes socially ideas,
once it reaches that 10% level,
Ooh,
it just falls down.
Fertility just falls down like a stone.
And,
uh,
in this period,
up here,
you can get all kinds of,
you know,
economic levels that different economic groups or having different fertility,
uh,
different educational groups.
So different difference between urban and rural in a different city,
whether their agricultural or in an industry.
And you can find all of these differences.
But once this fertility thing starts like this,
uh,
everybody does it.
These,
what they called,
these differentials,
the socioeconomic differentials just disappear.
And a farmer is just as likely to be limiting his fertility as a bourgeois,
uh,
person,
in,
in the cities.
And
so,
um,
if you try to think of how rapidly the economic situation change or how rapidly
does education increase,
and you look at all the various variables,
uh,
none of them increased with this kind of repeated,
none of them change.
Would that kind of a pillar,
infant mortality,
almost anything you can make it,
nothing goes with that kind of a rate.
So
what,
um,
what goes with that kind of a rate,
a fad or fashion that,
um,
let me try to find
this is this is the problem with my printer.
Well,
I'm not going to be able to find it.
I know the data.
So if you look all around Europe and this was in,
in,
in your region,
what you see is the date of the beginning of the decade.
This is the decade where that 10% level was reached and what,
what provinces are this perfect.
This is all France.
Then there's a long delay and surprisingly long delay and boom,
all the rest of Europe then does it [inaudible] basically,
uh,
most of it's done between 1870 and in 1930 it's almost all done.
So let's just sweep through Europe.
And again,
as I've showed you in the maps,
that includes Russia,
eastern Europe,
economically and educationally,
very underdeveloped,
uh,
kinds of places.
And yet the fertility drops.
This is all of Europe.
Nobody,
nobody is left out.
So again,
it makes it difficult to put an economic or an educational,
any of these other variables are on it.
And
what you have instead is,
and one,
one of these stories you read about in your reading,
remember that each of these graduate students and postdocs was put on a
different country of Europe and the Princeton project.
So one how to do England,
one ha and we'll have the one who did,
England is going to be guest lecture here next week,
next Thursday.
Um,
he's not going to talk about that because you'll have had enough in that by
then.
Um,
and there's a guy who's assigned Spain is guys William leasure and uh,
this I think you read a little bit about and he,
uh,
he gathered all this data,
huge amount of work,
you know,
in all the Spanish archives of every province from going way back to 1830 or
something and whatever,
whatever it was there he looked at and he put it all together and he could not
make any sense out of it whatsoever.
So this guy was going out of his mind and he took to drawing a map of fertility
rates,
sort of like these,
those kinds of maps.
I just showed you fertility rates at different points in time at the,
in the different provinces of Spain.
And,
and he showed it to everybody and you apparently was walking around campus one
day and he saw a professor of Spanish literature and who had met somewhere in
here button hold the guy and showed him the track and said,
I can't make any sense out of this.
Told,
told the professor what it was for.
As I said,
that's the linguistic regions of Spain.
And as you know,
Spain has a,
had a variety of kingdoms.
They were controlled by the Muslims and then the northern Christians kicked them
out and,
but there's Castiel and Navarro and Aragon and all of these cultural things and
still the Basques consider them still quite separate.
The Cadillac is consider themselves separate.
So Spain to this day has a serious regional diversity's.
And what apparently lecture had come up with unknowingly was a map of the
linguistic boundaries of ancient Spain,
ancient medieval Spain.
And they still remained in.
The idea that he came up with as well as it's fairly obvious,
is that people that could speak the same language,
the same dialect,
river,
a common culture,
would talk to each other and that it was social spread.
What kept the province a linguistic region,
uh,
uniform and it's fertility practices was the cultural spread that that was a
cultural unit as well as the linguistic in it.
And it didn't cross boundaries.
Another more quantified example of that is Belgium.
And here is Belgium.
And you know,
Belgium,
they speak two languages,
which are French and Flemish.
And Flemish is almost the same as Dutch,
which is almost the same as German there.
So it's a big divide,
the dramatic,
it's a dramatic romance language divide.
This is,
this is a big language divide.
And in Belgium here,
the various provinces of Belgium,
and uh,
these are the southern ones near Francis over here.
So these are all French speaking and Holland is up there in Germany is over
here.
These are the Flemish speaking of provinces.
And when you look at their fertility,
oops,
what is that?
Uh,
what happens is that there's another slide I don't want to find,
which,
oh,
no,
sorry.
This is messed up.
All right.
So,
uh,
when you look at their fertility,
France as you've heard a hundred times,
uh,
starts to fertility transition,
fertility drops.
There it goes,
it takes a fair amount of time,
but it goes first into French speaking,
Belgium and France speaking Belgium then conforms to,
to the,
uh,
to the French norm.
But then this is language line and you compare across that line and nothing,
nothing north of the line changes.
And it takes 60 years to cross that Lang,
that language line that I showed you.
I don't know what's going on here.
Stop this and getting to where I want to be.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
that isn't what I want.
Um,
so it takes 60 years to cross the,
the language barrier.
So this guy less tig,
uh,
the guy who studied,
who was assigned to do Belgium and he is Belgian has himself,
he said,
well,
what could be causing it?
What are the
differences between North,
south on,
aside from language?
When he was doing it,
they didn't really come up with this when he was originally,
when he started,
they didn't have understood this cultural difference and she was looking at
socioeconomic variables.
And so he took villages across that,
that boundary line there in who take no more than five kilometers difference and
he would take villages that were matched.
The soil was kind of the same.
The agricultural productivity was the same.
And every kind of socioeconomic variable that he could find was not different
across that line.
Uh,
except fertility that the northern line,
uh,
just had an awful lot more children than south of the line.
French speaking,
Flemish speaking,
and presuming the,
eliminating all of these socioeconomic variables by comparing these neighboring
towns all across from Belgium,
from east to west,
all across this line he looked at,
at,
at these kind of paired villages.
Well,
they said what,
what was doing it?
Well,
there's,
so they started thinking about cultural reasons and at that time in Europe there
were two through,
uh,
democracy was still fairly real.
Democracy was still fairly young,
but most everybody had the vote.
And there was a lot of discussion about who would control democracy,
whether democracy is good or bad thing.
So the suffrage,
the expanded kind of suffrage,
they still had kings and all that,
but the power was being eroded by parliaments.
And there were two sets of parties as really still are in Europe.
One was the Catholic party,
the Conservative Party called,
uh,
and the other was the Socialist Party.
So the Communist parties and anybody know,
so like Europe Union,
what they called the Social Democrats and in a variety of names,
other parties,
the Christian Demo,
there's really the parties that are still named Christian Democrats and Social
Democrats.
Like in Germany,
they pass their tests,
the,
um,
the premiere ship back and forth between them that was established at this time
and it was considered a fairly good marker for what we call secularization,
that how much a person was still believing in the old morality of the old style
things was,
was religious.
They would usually vote for the Christian Democrats,
people that had undergone some sort of a transition.
And now we're buying socialists theory or worker solidarity theory or believed
in unions would vote,
uh,
the,
the Democratic Socialist Party.
And what he did,
he said,
okay,
let's look at each of the provinces again.
And then this,
this is our own,
these mall,
which was smaller grouping then province and see what their vote is.
So here's the Catholic part and this is the percentage of non Catholic party.
And then he just compared this with how much their fertility had declined again,
always within,
within marriage.
And it turns out the more non-catholic cause they are,
the greater the decline in fertility.
It's kind of a,
uh,
a backwards thing.
So,
and very nice line of proportionality.
This is an exact proportionality in the points stick,
really very close to that line.
It's not hard to see what that line is.
And so people,
what became clear is that culturally people that were voting for the Catholic
party,
and therefore we're in the older mode of culture,
uh,
did not drop their fertility very much.
People who were voting,
the socialists of the left wing liberal,
whatever you want to call it,
way had dropped their fertility by 60 to 80%.
Huge drought in fertility.
So,
oh,
all right.
Um,
and these kinds of data kept coming.
Oh,
the
to conclude the,
um,
the bottom line is that in this Princeton project,
they just could not tie fertility,
changed any of the standard socioeconomic variables.
Now the word socioeconomic,
I think it's a terrible word.
I mean,
what does not either socio or economic?
So,
you know,
I always go around and ask people descriptions of it and I think it basically,
anything you can quantify and you get interesting variables like education,
and we'll see this sort of disastrously for understand the situation.
When you come into the third world,
education suits you for a better job,
especially women.
So when people get educated,
it's an economic variable because suits you for better job,
you can get higher pay.
It makes it more worth your while to go out and work other than stay home and
have children.
But Education also gives you a window on the world and makes a worldly person
open to new ideas,
a greater sense of agency that you can talk back to your husband or your mother
in law or Sofa.
So a lot of the variables,
you can't decide,
is this an economic variable or a social variable?
So it's kind of very unfortunate that they use this term socioeconomic variable,
but I think it was an early stage and understanding the problem and they,
they didn't know what to do about it.
Also,
uh,
another problem,
it's always in the social sciences when you're trying to do these studies,
getting the data itself is really very difficult.
And so since Europe has organized politically into provinces,
that's where the data was gathered.
And they had province level things.
They didn't have individual village,
uh,
level information.
They didn't have individual family kind of information.
When you do an aggregation,
even as finally as they could do,
I mean,
it's amazing to do every province in Europe.
So that was for the,
that period of,
of social science.
That was the low level of aggregation,
but still within each province.
Uh,
you have a huge range of people in very different circumstances and maybe you're
missing a lot by this aggregation.
So aggregation is a problem.
And since this period,
uh,
a lot of social science scholars have come back and argued tremendously over
this and say,
no,
they really are economic reasons for the fertility decline.
And we'll talk about those in a later lecture.
I just want to summarize what we've,
we spent a lot of time on this demographic transition and it's theory and a lot
of reading and every year the students say,
Oh,
I hated that part of the course.
But it is in a sense for the modern times,
it's the most important part of the course because everything else that you in
every understanding of the,
of what's happening now in developing countries is based on this stuff and
either agrees with it or disagrees with it or uses the same methodology,
are very self consciously tries to use a different methodology.
This is the foundation of the field.
So that's one reason you should know about it.
The other is,
it's such a tremendous,
uh,
change.
It may be.
To my mind,
it's the most important revolution ever in human history.
Look,
look what happens throughout this period.
Life people get to live three times as long,
right?
Imagine if you're at 20.
How many of you are under 20?
Okay.
Half of you,
you'd be dead,
right?
Half of this class would be dead if we weren't,
if we hadn't gone through,
uh,
this,
this transition of modernization,
he's happy about that.
The numbers of human beings,
the number of people that we now are able to keep alive as a fee is 10 times
larger.
Everyday it gets bigger.
But the last time I can't get 10 times larger than what we think the population
was back then.
So an enormous,
even though it's the introduction of contraception,
which limits the amount of people or tries to limit the amount of people,
in fact,
the number of people on earth has just expanded enormously,
both in numbers and in how long each one lives wealth individual per capita
wealth.
We saw that the industrial revolution by itself got into Malthusian problems and
didn't,
at least up until the,
the,
the fertility transition did not improve people's individual wealth.
Uh,
that required the combination of industrial revolution,
which increased production and fertility control,
which put a limit on the number of people trying to get advantage from that
increased production.
We've seen a tremendous democratization of marriage.
Imagine a society where 30% of only 70% of the people who are unmarried,
you know,
we sort of talk a lot about marriage and how marriage is going way as an
institution.
We are way,
way ahead of that.
China is way,
And so imagine I was that,
you know,
very few of you would have prospects of ever getting married because society
just didn't allow it.
And the same for sex as a,
as I've mentioned,
that democratization of sex,
your fertility coming under your individual control.
What a big change,
you know,
uh,
in life that you announced one of the big decisions you can make,
you know,
do I want some children,
many children,
fewer children,
whatever.
When do I want them?
All this comes under control within marriage.
Previously couples who are constantly under the pressure of constant
childbearing that the wife was always either pregnant or lactating.
Later,
I'll show you some statistics from the third world that women are almost never
free.
They're always either pregnant or lactating until they die and men had to go
out.
And this is a period when men was,
men were basically the breadwinners.
They had a support,
an ever increasing number of children under difficult economic circumstances.
So men and women were freed from,
from the requirement.
They had no choice.
The requirement of supporting,
taken care of and supporting these,
these large families.
There's,
there's so many issues that change during this time.
If you,
if any of you are thinking of doing term papers,
uh,
you just infinite number of things that have not even been looked at.
So for instance,
we talked a lot about an abandonment of children,
infanticide.
When do you think that disappeared?
Something in about this time,
you know,
you read about it into the 18 hundreds it was a lot of it and then it goes away.
There's a lot written about the period when it was heavy and much understanding
of why did infanticide disappear?
What does it do to this?
I don't know the answer.
I don't think it has been discovered.
Uh,
does,
uh,
investigate great term paper.
What about the romantic conception of marriage?
Marriage changes like this,
it becomes less of an economic thing,
less of a child bearing thing.
You don't need your wife to work,
especially on the farm.
Uh,
what is the tie in between romantic conceptions that we all now have about
marriage and love and all that and this whole demographic transition.
So in,
in almost every way you can think of modern culture,
this is that at the root of it,
that this is a thing that you always have to consider as whatever you believe.
However you're leading your life.
How much of it is due to these pioneers that we've talked about that started
controlling their fertility as an individual decision rather than as a,
as a community decision?
Okay.
So there's no,
no reading for today and,
uh,
because the lectures are now caught up with the reading.
So next week we'll talk on Tuesday,
and then on Thursday we have a guest lecturer.
The schedule changed from what you have.